Shure: RBG camera
Shure: 重新进一遍
Shure: Let's go back in
Shure:  呀好巧啊你们也在
Shure: Oh wow, what a coincidence to see you guys here
Shure:  哈喽哈喽
Shure: Hello, hello
其他人：真是意想不到啊
Others: Totally unexpected
Shure:  对不起对不起
Shure: Sorry, sorry
Jake:说明北京人人都有这个眼镜
Jake: Shows that everyone in Beijing has these glasses
Tasha: 我们居然能在这里偶遇
Tasha: I can't believe we ran into each other here
Shure:  真的
Shure: Really
Jake:日常情况
Jake: It's a normal thing
Shure:  mate在北京的普及率好高
Shure: The popularity of Mate in Beijing is really high
Lucia: 听过地域笑话
Lucia: Have you ever heard regional jokes?
Jake:至少在这密度极大
Jake: At least the density here is extremely high
Shure: 确实
Shure: Indeed
Shure:  在以我为什么半径
Shure: So why am I within this radius
Shure: 走
Shure: Let's go
Katrina: 我也不知道方向随便走吧
Katrina: I don't know the direction, let's just walk anywhere
Alice:今天18吗
Alice: Is today the 18th?
Lucia: 啊对
Lucia: Yeah, it is
Shure:  我靠有阳光有水
Shure: Wow, there's sunshine and water
Shure: 跳了
Shure: Let's jump
Katrina: 跳了爽了跳了
Katrina: Jump! Feels great, jump!
Shure:  往哪边走
Shure: Which way should we go?
其他人：啊这公园一眼望到头了就是这样一圈
Others: Ah, you can see the whole park from here, it's just a circle
Katrina: 蛮好的
Katrina: It's pretty nice
Shure: 我靠好渴
Shure: Wow, I'm so thirsty
Katrina: 喝啊
Katrina: Have a drink
Shure:  能喝吗这个不收费吗
Shure: Can I drink this? Is it free?
Shure:  哇哦
Shure: Wow
Shure: 呵呵呵神经病
Shure: Haha, crazy
Katrina:  感觉当时分手以后
Katrina: After the breakup, I felt like
Katrina:  就感觉整个人就重生了
Katrina: I was reborn
Katrina:  就是很神奇的那种感觉
Katrina: It was such a magical feeling
Katrina:  就是第一次体会到那种什么磁场不对
Katrina: It was the first time I experienced the wrong vibes
Katrina:  然后你整个人变
Katrina: And then I totally changed
Katrina:  然后就开始玩抽象
Katrina: And started getting abstract
Katrina:  哈哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahaha
Shure: 确实
Shure: Indeed
Katrina:  回归本性了
Katrina: Back to my true self
Katrina:  本来其实我初中高中
Katrina: Actually, in middle school and high school
Katrina:  我从小学开始就天天跟男生玩
Katrina: I’ve been hanging out with boys every day since primary school.
Katrina:  我爸妈就从来不管我这种谈恋爱
Katrina: My parents never cared about my dating life.
Katrina:  就是因为他们觉得我根本不会谈恋
Katrina: They think I’ll never date anyone.
Shure: 觉得你根本不会谈是吗
Shure: They think you’ll never date, huh?
Katrina:  对因为所有都处成哥们了
Katrina: Yeah, because I turn everyone into a buddy.
Katrina:  哇脏脏的dirt
Katrina: Ugh, dirty dirt.
Shure:  喂鱼吧
Shure: Feed the fish?
Shure:  啊我们有那什么
Shure: Oh, we've got that thing.
Shure:  弄下来一块
Shure: Grab a piece.
其他人：要不要披萨皮喂鱼吗
Others: Do you want to feed the fish with pizza crust?
Katrina:  呀哈吃这么好吗
Katrina: Wow, they’re eating so well.
Katrina:  给你们尝点达美乐
Katrina: Let’s give them some Domino’s.
Shure:  老北京鱼咱就得吃老北京美食
Shure: Old Beijing fish should eat Old Beijing food.
Katrina:  哈哈老北京鱼吃达美乐
Katrina: Haha, Old Beijing fish eating Domino’s.
Shure:   那叫一个地道
Shure: That’s authentic.
Shure:  拍一个来
Shure: Take a shot.
Katrina:  给你录呢
Katrina: I’m recording you.
Shure:  录着呢啊
Shure: You’re recording?
Katrina:  嗯
Katrina: Yeah.
Katrina:  他们近视吧
Katrina: They’re nearsighted, huh?
Katrina:  你看不见这么浑浊的水
Katrina: They can’t see how murky the water is.
Katrina:  哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahaha.
Shure: 应该能看见
Shure: They should be able to see.
Jake: 鼓掌有什么用
Jake: What’s the point of clapping?
Shure: 啊
Shure: Huh?
Jake: 鼓掌有什么用啊
Jake: What’s the point of clapping?
其他人：鼓掌在吸引他们过来看那边那边比较近
Others: Clapping attracts them, look over there, it’s closer.
Katrina:  哎有小鱼在吃
Katrina: Hey, there’s a little fish eating.
Jake: 鱼鱼鱼它鱼它有耳朵是吗
Jake: Fish, fish, do they have ears?
Katrina:  应该有吧
Katrina: They probably do.
Jake: 哦这么个音波是吧
Jake: Oh, it’s the sound waves, right?
Katrina:  哎呦很好这个抛的很准
Katrina: Wow, that throw was spot on.
Shure:  这素材够用吧
Shure: Is this footage enough?
其他人：好大一块啊
Others: That’s a big piece.
Shure: 卧槽他全吞了那个
Shure: Whoa, it swallowed the whole thing.
Katrina:  老北京鱼吃达美乐呀
Katrina: Old Beijing fish eating Domino’s.
Shure:  是啊那叫一个
Shure: Yeah, that’s what you call...
Alice:地地地地道哈哈哈哈
Alice: Authentic, hahaha.
Jake: 呵呵呵呵
Jake: Hahaha.
Shure:  滴滴嘀嗒地嘀嗒滴答滴滴答
Shure: Dee dee da da dee da da dee da dee da.
Shure:  滴滴答滴滴答
Shure: Tick-tock, tick-tock.
Shure: 什么饿了想吃了
Shure: What's that? Hungry and want to eat?
其他人：在这野餐啊
Others: Having a picnic here?
Jake: 和鱼一起吃
Jake: Eating with the fish.
Katrina:  开始的开吃
Katrina: Time to start eating.
Jake: 确实很离谱
Jake: This is really ridiculous.
Jake: 这个数据确实
Jake: These numbers are really...
Jake: 不知道为什么能看成这个样子
Jake: I don't know how they turned out like this.
Katrina:  哈哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahaha.
Tasha: 还在这等呢
Tasha: Still waiting here.
Shure: 就是 我们如果太偏离人类的正常行为的话
Shure: If we deviate too much from normal human behavior...
Jake: 哈哈好挺好的
Jake: Haha, it's pretty good.
Lucia: AI应该知道人类并不一直是理性人
Lucia: AI should know that humans aren't always rational.
Shure:  会污染
Shure: It will cause pollution.
Alice:哈哈还近一点
Alice: Haha, getting closer.
Katrina:  啊人类
Katrina: Ah, humans.
Jake: 是是是你也很特殊
Jake: Yes, yes, you are very special too.
Katrina:  这就是AI永远无法取取代人类的原因
Katrina: This is why AI can never replace humans.
Lucia: 虽然我知道
Lucia: Even though I know...
Lucia: 经济学家也老假设人类是理性人
Lucia: Economists often assume humans are rational.
Katrina:  因为人类总会做一些莫名其妙的行为
Katrina: Because humans always do some inexplicable things.
Katrina:  这就是人类
Katrina: That's just humans.
Jake: 局部是有逻辑的好吧
Jake: In some parts, it is logical, okay?
Jake: 局部上是有
Jake: In some parts, it is.
Jake: 就是你扔出去
Jake: Like when you throw it out.
Jake: 然后鱼吃披萨
Jake: And then the fish eat pizza.
Shure:  然后鱼过来
Shure: Then the fish come over.
Lucia: 嗯啊那么小的也有竟然
Lucia: Hmm, even such small ones, surprisingly.
Jake: 对这个是合理的
Jake: Yes, this is reasonable.
Jake: 然后你看到鱼扔披萨
Jake: And then you see fish throwing pizza.
Jake: 这个多少是有一点点逻辑的
Jake: 虽然不多
Jake: Though not much.
Shure:  啊
Shure: Ah.
Jake: 这些鱼应该什么都吃
Jake: These fish should eat anything.
Shure:  是的
Shure: Yes.
Jake: 公园里的鱼都是杂食类的鱼
Jake: The fish in the park are omnivores.
Jake: 鱼肉可以吃吗
Jake: Can fish meat be eaten?
Alice:妈耶
Alice: Oh my god.
Shure:  废话我们刚刚看了那个
Shure: Nonsense, we just saw that.
Lucia: 大鱼吃小鱼
Lucia: Big fish eat small fish.
Shure:  发现海里鱼都是在吃自己的东西同类
Shure: Found that fish in the sea are all eating their own kind.
Shure:  然后评论难道猪能在海里吗哈哈哈
Shure: Then someone commented, "Can pigs live in the sea?" Hahaha
Katrina:  哈哈在海里的不都鱼吗哈哈哈
Katrina: Haha, aren't all sea creatures fish? Hahaha
Lucia: 哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahahahahahaha
Shure:  再分你们点来
Shure: Let me give you some more.
Alice:颐和园的大雁都还挑食呢
Alice: Even the swans at Summer Palace are picky eaters.
Jake: 这都吃完了
Jake: It's all gone.
Jake: 哈哈哈这都吃完了这个
Jake: Hahaha, it's all gone.
Shure:  啊拿多累啊
Shure: It's so tiring to get more.
Tasha:  在湖边喂喂鱼
Tasha: Feeding fish by the lake.
Shure:  喂着喂着
Shure: While feeding...
Shure:  自己饿了
Shure: I got hungry myself.
Jake: 对呀一会有海鸥怎么办
Jake: Yeah, what if seagulls come?
Jake: 还有东西喂吗
Jake: Do we still have anything to feed them?
Tasha: 麦当劳薯条
Tasha: McDonald's fries.
Shure:  这有海鸥
Shure: There are seagulls here.
Alice:海鸥找点薯条喂他
Alice: Find some fries to feed the seagulls.
Alice:这个可以仍一下吗
Alice: Can I throw this?
Jake: 还有一盒
Jake: There's one more box.
其他人：哦抛洒了
Others: Oh, it spilled.
Jake: 好像恐怖
Jake: Looks scary.
Lucia: 呵呵抛洒
Lucia: Haha, it spilled.
Jake: 骨灰呵呵
Jake: Like ashes, haha.
Tasha: 好爽啊
Tasha: Feels great.
Lucia: 披萨也可以算是一种面的骨灰是吧
Lucia: Pizza could be considered dough ashes, right?
Jake:嗯对
Jake: Yeah, right.
其他人：这也算一个码头吗
Others: Is this also a dock?
Jake: 对小码头
Jake: Yeah, a small dock.
Jake: 这叫什么湖啊有名字吗
Jake: What's this lake called? Does it have a name?
Katrina:  未名湖
Katrina: Unnamed Lake.
Alice:未名湖
Alice: Unnamed Lake.
Jake: 好哈哈哈哈哈
Jake: Alright, hahahaha.
Lucia: 哈哈哈哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahahahaha.
Alice:哈哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha.
Katrina:  AI又疑惑了哈哈
Katrina: The AI is confused again, haha.
Tasha:  难道是我扔的不够远吗
Tasha: Did I not throw it far enough?
Shure:  看好了
Shure: Watch closely.
Lucia: 哈哈
Lucia: Haha.
Jake: 这边可以预测哪只鱼可以吃得到
Jake: You can predict which fish will get it from here.
Tasha:  哈哈你看我的在那后面就不是吃
Tasha: Haha, look at mine at the back, it's not eating.
Katrina:  那是抛物线
Tasha:  必须要抢才行
Shure:  你想落哪我就能落哪
Shure:  看那边去了
Shure:  那是死了吗
Tasha:  你看开始抢了开始吃了
Katrina:  问一下AI那是活的
Shure:  那是活的吗
Jake: 啊还有死的呀
Katrina:  那塑料袋吧
Shure:  那是塑料袋还是鱼啊
Katrina:  那
Jake: 那那个
Shure: 啊那是活的应该
Jake:那漂这的吗
Shure: 看好了
其他人：哦什么掉了
Katrina:  嗯手串
Katrina:  手串吗
Tasha:  手链吗
Shure:  啊
Shure: Ah
Katrina:  完了被女朋友骂死
Katrina: Oh no, my girlfriend's gonna kill me.
Shure:  啊
Shure: Ah
Tasha:  掉到湖里了
Tasha: It fell into the lake.
Katrina:  哈哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahaha
Jake: 他自己应该记得吧
Jake: He should remember it himself.
Tasha:  记录下来了
Tasha: It's recorded.
Katrina:  我的眼镜应该看到了
Katrina: My glasses should have seen it.
Jake: 你自己也记了
Jake: You remembered it yourself too.
Shure:  没救了啊
Shure: It's hopeless.
Katrina:  滑动摩擦力太小了
Katrina: The sliding friction was too low.
Alice:这个好像也不是很深
Alice: It doesn't seem very deep here.
Alice:要不提供点珍贵素材
Alice: Maybe we can get some valuable footage.
Shure:  这
Shure: This...
Shure: 那怎么还就剩鱼头了呢
Shure: How come only the fish head is left?
其他人：哦别说太太
Others: Oh, don't say that!
Alice:啊
Alice: Ah
Jake: 呃应该是被吃了嗯
Jake: Uh, it was probably eaten.
Tasha:  应该是被大鱼吃小鱼的时候吃掉了
Tasha: It must have been eaten when the big fish ate the smaller fish.
Tasha:  那头鱼不喜欢吃鱼头
Tasha: That fish doesn't like eating fish heads.
其他人：那个手链的精神和情感价值有吗
Others: Does that bracelet have any sentimental or emotional value?
Katrina:  准备好回去下跪吧搓衣板
Katrina: Get ready to go back and kneel on a washboard.
Jake: 或者是别的一些生物
Jake: Or maybe some other creatures.
Jake: NPU那边有水獭
Jake: There are otters at NPU.
Jake: 水獭吃鱼
Jake: Otters eat fish.
Lucia: 有什么奇怪景象吗让我的眼镜也看一看
Lucia: Is there anything strange? Let me take a look with my glasses.
Jake: 吃一半就丢路边
Jake: They eat half and throw the rest on the roadside.
Shure: 我考应该就是通州旁边吗
Shure: I guess it's near Tongzhou?
Shure: 哎
Shure: Hey.
Alice:你要捞一下吗找个棍
Alice: Do you want to scoop it out? Find a stick.
Shure: 我天上哪 儿捞去啊
Shure: How am I supposed to scoop it out from the sky?
Alice:大概在哪个位置呢
Alice: About where is it?
Alice:这一片吧
Alice: Around this area?
Shure:  不事儿承认错误吧
Shure: No, just admit the mistake.
Jake: 你问问问问有没有那大网子是吧
Jake: Ask around if there's a big net or something.
Shure:  不用捞了不用捞了 没事
Shure: No need to scoop it out, it's fine.
Jake: 在哪啊
Jake: Where is it?
Shure: 肯定沉进去了
Shure: It must have sunk.
Jake:这一片是吗
Jake: Around this area, right?
其他人：嗯
Others: Yeah.
Jake:嚯跟鱼头在一块差不多
Jake: Whoa, it's probably with the fish heads.
Jake:走吧
Jake: Let's go.
Jake:去下一个景点这是什么景点
Jake: To the next spot. What spot is this?
Tasha: 湖边喂鱼景点
Tasha: The lakeside fish feeding spot.
Shure:  差不多
Shure: Pretty much.
Shure:  完了这不会是哥的老家附近吧
Shure: Oh no, this might be near my hometown.
其他人：是一个珠子的残骸吗
Others: Is it the remains of a bead?
Shure:  有一个能交代就行
Shure: As long as there's one to account for.
Tasha: 把一个然后屌成项链
Tasha: Make one into a necklace then.
Katrina:  真的吗那是散开了
Katrina: Really? It's scattered?
Katrina:  我以为是直接这样子出去了
Katrina: I thought it just went out like that.
Shure:  散开了
Shure: It's scattered.
其他人：应该直接爆开了
Others: It probably exploded directly.
Shure:  应该是我这个东西他他压到了然后
Shure: It must have been pressed by something and then...
Katrina:  我当时特别害怕你把眼镜甩出去了
Katrina: I was really scared you would throw your glasses away.
Alice:那看来捞不出来了它既然散开就只剩珠子了
Alice: Looks like we can't scoop it out. Since it's scattered, only the beads are left.
Shure: 哎
Shure: Yeah.
Katrina:  你把这一个串一下戴戴成项链吗
Katrina: Can you string these together and wear it as a necklace?
Shure: 行
Shure: Sure.
Katrina:  我心永在
Katrina: My heart remains forever.
Shure: 还牵着狗就是
Shure: And holding a dog, just...
Shure: 哎
Shure: Hey
Katrina:  节哀
Katrina: My condolences
Shure:  让我这个美丽的下午突然不美丽了
Shure: This beautiful afternoon suddenly became not so beautiful.
Shure:  说刚才手链怎么突然爆开了呢我靠
Shure: How did the bracelet suddenly break? Damn.
Alice:其实我平时穿衣服都是花里胡哨的
Alice: Actually, I usually dress in flashy clothes.
其他人：啊是吗
Others: Oh, really?
Shure:  咱们去的就是这边吧应该这个公园
Shure: We're going to this park, right?
Alice:这是我为数不多的浅色衣服
Alice: This is one of the few light-colored clothes I have.
Shure:  我靠真的像被反噬了一样
Shure: Damn, it really feels like I got counterattacked.
Shure:  我刚才扔那个面包喂鱼嘛
Shure: I just threw that bread to feed the fish.
Shure:  然后手链就突然就崩开了整个
Shure: Then the bracelet just suddenly snapped completely.
Shure:  然后全掉到湖里了
Shure: And everything fell into the lake.
Shure:  只有一个掉在外面了
Shure: Only one piece fell outside.
Alice:这里面吗
Alice: In here?